tunisia's president kai syed has
appointed a new prime minister he's
attached to national buddhism with
forming a government she'll be the first
woman to do so the move comes after four
political parties formed a coalition to
oppose said on tuesday opposition
politicians have warned they'll call for
more protests unless he reverses his
move to seize power well barnard smith
is in tunis for us this is coming at a
time of great pressure for the president
isn't it
and najla boudin ramdan is now
going to take on a lot of that pressure
she was until today a little-known
professor of engineering previously
she'd worked for the world bank and now
she's been thrust right into the heart
of the spotlight and
tunisia's political crisis now
ordinarily under the tunisian
constitutional system the president
appoints the prime minister
who then appoints members of her cabinet
and this all has to be approved by
parliament but the president has
suspended parliament so he's appointed
najla buden ramdan as prime minister but
there'll be no parliamentary
approval of this now one of the
complaints
of the civil society groups and this
coalition of political parties who spoke
on tuesday was that president kai side
in the last two months had not spoken to
them had not approached them had not
tried to engage them in dialogue and
this prime minister has been appointed
without
the
discussions with the political parties
do we do not yet know what their
reaction is going to be to her
appointment whether that will calm
things down for the time being
bernard thanks very much indeed that's
bernard smith live for us in tunis let's
bring in sheriff hadi he's a political
commentator and a former parliamentary
officer so he's joining us live from
tunis as well good to have you with us
on al jazeera just taking up on the
point that barnabas was making there if
there is no parliament how does this
work
well if there is no parliament this is
going to work according to the last
presidential order the order 117
that is the
prime minister designate mrs
will form a cabinet and then this
cabinet will be just maybe formally
approved uh by sworn in ceremony
in front of the president i sighed
so literally and unfortunately there
will be no parliamentary approval for
this for this cabinet and according to a
recent video published minutes ago
in which prison side
they delivered a little speech of a few
minutes
with the presence of mrs budden the
government the new cabinet would be
formed in the next few hours or a few
days at
the president i would imagine must have
known what the the political process is
and therefore would have known that
having no parliamentary approval for the
appointment of a prime minister is
essentially rendering it somewhat in
ineffective
why do you think he's trying to achieve
by doing this
well a present by side has been quite
clear even since the presidential
campaign
he is against or opposed to many parts
of the 2014 constitution he wants a new
regime and he is uh
really willing to change the the
political system uh at probably any
cause and it's now quite clear
especially after the decision of
september 22nd with the presidential
order
but he is willing to change it at any
cost whatever
the
political parties are saying or their
positions and he's counting mainly on
the huge uh popular support that he's uh
that he has uh till now till today so uh
president kaisei is moving uh forward
with with his uh
clear intention of reforming amending
the constitution the political system
and
his philosophy of bottom-up
democracy and the main targets
according to the last speech of the
president of this cabinet would be uh
first first of all fighting corruption
and then uh delivering the necessary
daily needs or daily life the daily life
needs for tunisians transportation
education infrastructure
so
and counting on that the fact that this
first female prime minister this would
uh
this could be seen as a peer stand or a
new legitimacy for uh for the president
high side we will see in the upcoming
hours and days
tell us a little bit about the new prime
minister there seems to be very little
about her in a very brief search
admittedly
online what do you know about her
background has she got a sort of
government experience that would be
relevant to the post
she was
let's say the her only political
experience that she was member of the uh
cabinet of the uh minister of higher
education in 2015
but now she's in charge of implementing
the programs of the world bank in the in
the same minister of higher education
but uh talk about political experience i
think just like president hai said
she is rather an academician
from the academic sphere rather than
being from the political sphere that is
rejected by the president and the
population as well for now
you mentioned before that there was uh
significant support for the president in
tunisia and what he's attempting to do
at the same time of course there is also
significant opposition we've seen the
protests in the streets against um
suggestions for example that he is
invite is essentially a coup that he's
seizing power we've seen the opposition
groups who've been forming this
coalition
to oppose him
do you think that this in any way is
going to be seen as
some
step forward for the president in an
effort to try and satisfy his opponents
do you think his opponents are actually
going to accept any of this including of
course those who are opposed to him on
the streets of tunisia
i don't so far when we don't have the
the feedback from the main political
parties uh representing the main
opposition to to to side decision
but what is what is quite obvious and
clear that according to at least the
positions of the four uh uh
four political parties that held press
conferences today in tunis uh
affect tunas uh democratic current uh
the forum for uh for for liberties and
in in addition to the republican party
it's quite clear that they're not
considering to work with this government
according to to their last statements
maybe the position would change in the
upcoming hours and weeks
but this for sure would need a sort of
dialogue between them and the whether
the cabinet or the president and a new
let's say rules of the uh of the actual
game because so far what we are seeing
is that the president is willing to
to to discuss with with no one no
dialogue whatsoever so far
sheila ferrari we appreciate you as
always being on al jazeera thank you
mary very much indeed for your time